ab und zu
läuft
nobody's perfect
mein name ist nobody
ganz viel
nee
das interessant aber ich vermisse das
nicht mit meiner musik
messer
die spitze vom zahnarzt
zu selten leider gottes
sehr groß
ich versuche mich zu zügeln
vor gott und den finanzen
und ein bisschen vor papa
alles was sie wollen
größter respekt wichtigsten personen
richtige adresse
früher aber jetzt weniger
ganz wichtig dann zwischen new friends
keine neuen freunde bleibt bei den alten
freunden die schon vor deiner karriere
vor allem gekanntes und ökonomisch nein
beste zeit sollte man auf jeden fall
zu schätzen wissen weil es einfach zu
schnell vorbei geht und dann das echte
leben anfängt
gesunde neugier gegenüber
dinge die geschehen aber nicht jetzt
unbedingt gegenüber irgendwelchen
personen die man es trocken ist oder so
wichtig
kommt darauf an mit wem man macht es
sehr viel spaß aber wenn jemand
unerfahren ist interviewt und british
english aus dem konzert auf der bühne
des öfteren früher auf jeden fall des
öfteren mittlerweile profis wirklich
sehr
um ehrlich zu sein musste ich erstmal
nachdenken
vor was ich angst habe es sagt es gibt
keine personen oder
eine
oder viele bestimmte ereignisse die die
mir angst machen ist tatsächlich das
finanzamt und gott
ich mein die angst vor sozialer
gegenwärtig aber das finanzamt macht nur
auf jeden fall auch ab und zu mal angst
was es sei schön im schatten des öfteren
mal briefe bekommen wo ich bis in den
fünfstelligen bereich bezahlen musste
und wenn sie das mehrmals mehr bekommst
dann ist es nicht angenehm auf jeden
fall
deutschland deutschland wenn euch das
ihr gefallen hat dann geht er auf
hometown dort gibt es noch mehr von mir
oder ihr abonniert den bingern channel
wo es ganz ganz viele andere videos gibt
zum einen sensationellen album babas
barbies und bargeld